[Music]
the popular social media platform
Instagram has a new feature to filter
out hateful comments tool uses a type of
artificial intelligence called machine
learning a group of about 20 people is
now teaching the program what are
considered mean or inappropriate posts
CBS News contributor and wired
editor-in-chief Nick Thompson visited
instagrams offices he sat down with the
company's co-founder and CEO Kevin
Systrom for tonight's CBS n on
assignments here's a preview
the first thing you notice walking into
Instagram is a big photo booth naturally
and a massive display where visitors can
write and post comments the
old-fashioned way
most of these are quite nice don't stop
believin encore you are long you are
beautiful this heart and the one and the
badge has become iconic for kindness on
the platform but not everything is
exactly loving and kind for Instagram
users I'm gonna read some of the
comments on at Kevin's post sure these
are the comments suck suck suck can you
make Instagram have Auto scroll feature
you suck suck min stop the meme genocide
make Instagram great again it's a good
example of how someone can get bullied
right they imagine you're you know
someone who's trying to express yourself
about depression or anxiety or body
image issues and you get that yeah does
that make you want to come back and post
on the platform and they not and if
you're seeing that does that make you
want to be open about those issues as
well
no and that's why sistrum has made it
his mission to make kindness itself the
theme of Instagram through two new
phases first eliminating toxic comments
a feature that launched the summer and
then second elevating nice comments
which will roll out later this year our
unique situation in the world is that we
have this giant community that wants to
express themselves can we have an
environment where they feel comfortable
to do that Nick also writes about
instagrams new developments in the
September issue of Wired a magazine it's
a great article you should check it out
Nick good morning to you how are you
part of this is encouraging and I think
part of its scary a little bit when
you're trying to decide what's mean
what's toxic I mean the thought is there
right but how does he figure that out I
mean what's so interesting so they've
spent the last year trying to make
Instagram nicer and this new stage
they've built a system so that when you
type something in but machines will scan
it and delete it automatically so it's
not a human judging that a comment is
toxic
it's a machine judging that it's toxic
the advance the human teaching the
machine how to do it well the process is
built right so the way the system
learned is 20 humans sat in a room they
read through thousands and thousands of
comments this
toxic not toxic toxic not toxic they
then put all those ratings into the
machines which then came up with a set
of rules those rules now serve as the
filters on Instagram cleaning it up
which this Sun is great better
conversations nicer conversation and the
some wait a second yeah any element of
censorship here definitely an element of
censorship and what system will say to
that is no we're not censoring speech
we're just censoring insults like those
things I read on the clip people just
saying nasty repulsive things the system
is set up really only to knock out the
worst stuff so system says that should
be okay that's not a violation of free
speech so could the same artificial
intelligence that does that type of
censoring also be used to censor
ideological content you could you could
set it up that way you could filter out
either logical content you could elevate
certain kinds of political content I
mean this is one of the most interesting
questions that we're gonna have in the
next years of social media the decisions
the people who run social media
platforms make have a profound effect on
Congress that you know Facebook has said
we're not in the business of censorship
or filtering out the fake news whatever
it is right and so the companies get to
make a set of choices what Instagram is
done is they said we're gonna make a set
of choices to try to elevate kindness
and get rid of toxicity we'll see what
the other companies do you know what's
interesting is that Instagram is owned
by Facebook Nick Thompson thank you very
much I find Instagram for a safe place
you can see next full report on CBS n on
assignment tonight at 10:00 9:00 central
on CBS and our streaming network cbsn